et pour en parler nous sommes avec
stéphane rozès président de cap conseils
analyses perspectives enseignant à
sciences po et hec également bon ce par
stéphane rozès merci d'être avec nous
quand on voit l'agitation que cela
provoque depuis plusieurs jours à ce que
pour vous la faire griveaux est devenue
clairement une affaire d'état une
affaire d'état peut-être pas dans la
mesure où au fond rapidement elle a
trouvé une solution du point de vue de
la majorité par le départ même de mach
malgré vous mais c'est une affaire qui a
secoué l'état très certainement vous
l'avez dit ça a été une sorte d' onde de
choc parce que le candidat la république
en marche au moment des faits était
aussi ministre du gouvernement et donc
il ya un effet de stupeur s'il n'ya
jamais eu comme ça en cours de campagne
municipale
le une tête de lice comme ça en
métropole aussi importante qui se retire
un et donc agnès buzyn à la charge peu
évidente de reprendre le flambeau sur
pareil et donc l'arrivée d'agnès biesen
est une personnalité forte importante
dans le dispositif la marque roignot
font tourner la page
politiquement de ça alors il peut y
avoir des effets encore de cette affaire
sur la philosophie de l'exécutif sur les
choix parle par exemple les réseaux
sociaux va y avoir des développements
judiciaires visiblement on l'a vu dans
les effets donc il va y avoir encore des
ddd traînée de cette affaire au plan
donc peut-être éventuellement législatif
au plan judiciaire c'est clair mais la
séquence politique elle même a été
rapidement conclues par l'arrivée
d'ânesse butin qui fait bouger les
lignes à paris et qui au fond remet
l'attention du public sur des dimensions
politiques et moins de morale politique
l'observateur que vous êtes direct
emmanuel macron l'exécutent le chef de
l'exécutif a plutôt bien
et cette séquence du mieux qu'il a pu en
tout cas alors j'allais dire l'analyste
indépendant que je suis presque une fois
n'est pas coutume le choix d'agnès busin
me semble être un très bon choix
pourquoi parce que le sujet des
parisiens est au fond est ce qu'on
maîtrise toujours nous parisien le
développement de paris et le quotidien
des parisiens étaient très bousculés
dans la dernière période
et si la chaude la réforme des retraites
mais surtout le quotidien s'est dégradée
le fait que 60 % des parisiens ne
souhaite pas la reconduction d'anne
hidalgo dit suffisamment le bilan
négatif qui est le sien ce qui n'est pas
coutumier des grands mères or elles
naissent butin par sa façon d'être sa
façon de faire le fait que ça soit un
médecin qu'elles sont en rupture avec le
style benjamin griveaux était un style
de disruption qui était un style
agressif qui était un style de critiques
de ses adversaires au contraire agnès
buzyn par sa façon d'être et de faire
semblant en mesure de réparer de
rassembler de pacifier et le challenge
même que le sien en en a' mois à trouver
une solution fait que spontanément les
parisiens se disent il faudrait
peut-être l'aider temps ça semble
incroyable le défi qui est le sien à
vous entendre à ce que ce qui pouvait
paraître comme un séisme est en tout cas
une très mauvaise nouvelle pour quoi
emmanuel macron pourrait s'avérer être
une bonne nouvelle pour lui oui
absolument parce que toute façon la
campagne de benjamin griveaux était
mauvaise cédric villani qui n'avait pas
de soutien et a été à son niveau
quasiment donc benjamin griveaux c'était
fini il y avait un duel annoncé anne
hidalgo rachida dati qu'évidemment
auraient profité à anne hidalgo de ces
buttes ou burqa rachida dati n'est pas
en situation de rassembler une majorité
de parieurs et donc paradoxalement si
manipulation consciente
il n'y a eu sur la ferme
vaud la réponse du président mâcon en
fait de permettre alors le mois qui
arrive va le démontrer pas mais selon
moi elle à agnès buzyn a du fun du sujet
des parisiens a de bonnes chances a
fortiori si elle a dorénavant avec l
cédric villani de l'emporter la mise en
examen de la compagne de pyatt repas
plein ce qui est de ce dernier à 1 ce
soir c'est la suite logique de cette
affaire rien à signaler à ce niveau là
il y à il ya des lois en la matière est
évidemment comprend pourquoi l'exécutif
a voulu non pas attendre focaliser sur
la faute
faites par benjamin griveaux qui a de
lui-même rendu possiblement public
quelque chose lié à sa vie privée
d'autant plus a fortiori vu les
circonstances de la relation avec la
personne et donc on comprend bien
pourquoi en réaction de défense
d'exécutif a voulu pointer au fond ce
qui ont instrumentalisé et question des
réseaux sociaux donc logiquement et
pizzas ou s'il ya une législation sur
l'utilisation des données ou par la
justice entre part je suis pas
d'ailleurs du tout associé de ces
questions là donc la justice va faire
son travail inculpé ça veut pas dire pas
mais c'est assez logique qu'au fond on
s'y attendait à un tout petit peu que
effectivement la justice soit si vous
parlez de la réaction de l'exécutif pour
le secrétaire d'état d'ailleurs au
numérique cedrico il faut rétablir
justement la peur du gendarme sur
internet en permettant notamment à la
justice et la police d'intervenir plus
rapidement en cas de violation de la loi
en ligne c'est une occasion toute
trouvée de formuler des restrictions
encore une fois on connaît cette
appétence hommes ce gouvernement à
vouloir maîtriser
usages d'internet dès que la ferc rivaux
est arrivé on a vu député importante de
la république en marche d'hier car il
faudrait peut-être gendarmes et aussi
twitter regarder ce qui se passe dans
les autres pieds tout ça alors bon il ya
des lois il ya il ya des instances
indépendantes qui vérifie toutes ces
questions et au fond il ya une forme de
cohérence
si au fond la sphère griveaux c'est
essentiellement un problème lié à
l'articulation entre libertés publiques
liberté d'expression droit à l'intimité
du coup on voit que les choses alors je
ne sais pas le tricot a fait
effectivement une déclaration ce soir
vous avez raison bon on va voir ce qu'il
en est parce que entre les déclarations
et concrètement ce que l'on fait c'est
très différent parce qu'il ya aussi un
état de droit dans notre pays alors il
ya une déliquescence de l'esprit public
clairement et au delà de la faute de
benjamin griveaux et des
instrumentalisations possible qu'elle
soit par l'ultra gauche ou une puissance
étrangère par exemple la russie mais
c'est pas ça selon moi la question
essentielle
d'abord la question première d'abord a
été de la faute de benjamin griveaux et
donc le depor sur la question des
réseaux sociaux est un des ports dont je
me demande si au fond il va aboutir
puisque comme je les dis la situation
sur pareil et éclaircies et s'il y avait
eu manipulation ce serait l'arroseur
arrosé
et au fond les français passent à une
autre séquence parce que cette affaire
les a déstabilisés nous ne sommes pas
les états unis il ya eu des manquements
néanmoins
de la part d'une personnalité politique
et les français n'aiment pas voir des
moeurs qui semble être des à tort ou à
raison des moeurs d'autres pays
s'immiscer dans le républicanisme qui
est le nôtre et on parlait des français
selon un sondage et nab pour nos
confrères de bfm tv 50 % d'entre eux se
disent choqués par la diffusion publique
de ses vidéos intimes attribué à
benjamin griveaux pourtant c'est vrai
que politique on l'a vu et journalistes
d'ailleurs semblé tenir un discours
assez unique sur les plateaux de télé
victimisant souvent je crois qu'on peut
le dire mais jamais griveaux à part
peut-être quelques opinions divergentes
votre regard justement vous sur ce
traitement médiatique de cette affaire
il était assez inédit honnêtement la
question n'est pas simple moi tout de
suite j'ai dit d'abord benjamin griveaux
avait créé les conditions 8 même par le
fait qu'il avait produite cette vidéo et
qu'il avait transmises à une tierce
personne en dehors des liens familiaux
et conjugaux qui faisait que forcément
il se mettait en péril et que donc
séduit qui s'est mis en péril qui a mis
en péril la république en marche qui a
mis en péril le débat public
ensuite il ya la question de
l'instrumentalisation politique mais au
départ il ya une origine et il n'y a des
effets et donc ça a été ma première
réaction pourquoi parce que l'homme
politique à une charge il a une
obligation c'est pas un citoyen comme
les autres et donc il doit se conformer
amis même si nous ne sommes pas les noms
et les états unis il doit protéger la
fonction
or benjamin griveaux n'a pas protégé la
fonction politique il lâcha h était la
sienne
merci beaucoup stéphane rozès un rappel
vous êtes président de conseils analyses
perspectives enseignant en sciences po
et hec merci à vous